In Iran, at least 40 people were killed and more than 200 injured...
...in a stampede at the crowded funeral for Qassem Soleimani, state television reports.
In the US, Secretary of State Mike Pompeo says Qassem Soleimani...
...posed a distinct threat to Americans in the Middle East,...
...but again publicly offered no specific evidence of any attack he was about to carry out.
In Venezuela, opposition leader Juan Guaido and several dozen deputies...
...who support him as President of Parliament forcibly entered the Legislative Palace,...
...after being held for almost an hour by the militarized police.
A series of earthquakes, including a 6.4 magnitude quake, have struck the island of Puerto Rico,...
...causing heavy damage in some areas and cutting power to a large part of the island.
Finally from Australia, rain and cooler temperatures have allowed firefighters...
...to shore up defenses against the massive bushfires...
...that have burned millions of hectares over three months.